And I think that's part of the reason why human beings can be so infinitely
creative,
right?
For us,
the world isn't fixed.
We never know what it's going to bring forth.
So 100 years ago,
if someone would have said,
well,
you could build a machine on a wafer,
a centimeter square out of sand,
and if you have enough of those machines,
than everyone in the world can be connected.
And everyone in the world can have an infinite library of verbal material,
right?
That's impossible.
But it's not impossible.
It turns out that Silica has those properties and we can build unbelievably
powerful machines out of nothing.
And so then that kind of makes you think about just what this.
Nothing that we're building things out of his right,
because it seems to be able to reveal a constant array of properties.
Properties that are essentially unlimited and its capacity to reveal those
properties seems to depend as much on our ability to interact with it.
Whatever that is,
as it does on whatever the stuff is.
And we know even from a strict object perception of the world that the stuff
that things are made of is a lot more complicated than we had originally
presumed,
even as materialists because materialists realists,
there are philosophy only holds down to about the subatomic level of analysis.
Deterministic worldview below the subatomic level of analysis.
There's nothing deterministic at all and the stuff that things are made of is so
mysterious that we can't even.
We can't grasp,
but we can't comprehend it.
So it turns out that rather than the story world be being dependent on the
object world,
it might be the other way around.
The object world is dependent on the story world and that implies at least to
some degree that the story world is actually more real.
Whatever that means.
And then I told you that,
well,
the real problem of life isn't so much what do you do when you're around things
that you understand?
The real problem of life is what do you do when you encounter something you
can't conceptualize?
And I think a good recent example of that was the bombing of the world trade
towers,
which people were compelled to watch over and over and over and over.
And if you ask someone,
well what is it that you're watching?
They would say,
well,
I'm watching the world trade towers fall down,
but then you might say,
well why are you watching it over and over?
And they would say something like,
well,
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it's happening.
And what does that mean?
It means something like whatever it is that's happening here,
whatever's being blown apart exceeds my ability to model.
And as a consequence I have to expose myself to it again and again and again and
again to try to understand what's falling,
what's falling exactly.
Is it just the.
Is it just the Towers is at 20,000 people?
Is that the financial system of the u?
S is the stability of the Western world is at the beginning of world war three
or as the former CIA director just mentioned in the u,
the beginning of World War for what is it exactly that you're looking at?
When something happens that you don't understand
and then you'll say,
well,
how do you react to that?
And it turns out that you react mostly with your body,
not with your mind,
not with your perceptual systems,
not with your thoughts,
but with your emotions and your body,
and that means you sweat and you panic and you feel depressed and you feel hurt
and you feel ashamed and you're prepared for a catastrophe which is stress and
all that basically noncognitive.
And what that means is that when you encounter something you don't understand,
the first manner in which you conceive of it is embodied emotional,
physical way.
Before you develop up an object representation or cognitive representation,
you may not ever get it like an event like that or a worse event can throw
someone into a tailspin that's so extreme that they never get out of it.
So you see,
for example,
sometimes,
and this is more true among elderly people,
if their spouse dies,
the probability that they'll die in the next year,
say from a heart attack or something like that,
increases substantially.
Why is that?
It's because they're conceptual frame was so dependent on the existence of their
spouse.
Say someone they've lived with for 25 years that the anxiety and uncertainty
caused by their anomalous disappearance there death is so extreme that it sends
their body into a physiological state that's basically unbearable and that does
the men,
and when you start to understand what having your preconceptions rattled really
means,
then you also start to understand why people are so motivated to protect their
ideological territory,
right?
Because ideological territory,
that's how you see the world.
That's your story and you can't have your fundaments rattled all the time
because it throws everything into chaos and that puts you in this terrible,
panicky cortisol written stressful state that's really hard on you physically.
So we know,
for example,
that if you're in a state where you're chronically exposed to threat or
punishment,
which is the case in depression,
say you produce a lot of cortisol,
which is a stress hormone and cortisol is toxic,
so the more of it you produce,
the more you kill off your hippocampal cells and you really need them because
they are key to memory.
You do in your immunological system.
There's all sorts of negative side effects of cortisol poisoning,
increased incidents of cardiovascular disease,
heightened grade IV cancer,
plus it's just no fun,
right?
It's the worst thing that can possibly happen to you essentially.
If something I know it happens to you in blows your frame of reference,
right,
knocks you for a loop,
sends you to the underworld,
however you want to construe it,
that's really going to upset your bandwagon and throw you into a state that you
do virtually anything to avoid.
But by the same token,
there is a possibility that inside that chaotic mess,
there's something you really need.
And what's the logic there?
Well,
the logic is something like this.
When you look at the world,
you only see a fragment of it and that's good because it's pretty overwhelming
and a fragments generally more than enough,
but all the information that you've ever gathered in your entire life to build
yourself out of and to make your life stable has come as a consequence of your
ability to explore what you don't understand,
and that's an unlimited capacity,
right?
No matter how much you explored,
how much information you gather,
there's always the possibility that there's way more information out there and
that means if you have a problem and you see that it's a problem,
even though that's frightening,
it's also a gateway into a domain of possibility and the possibility is this
richly informative background that could in principle provide you with any
answer you need and then you can take one more thing.
And the old Gods,
Mars say the God of war,
Venus,
the god of love,
they're all internalized for us,
right?
We know that anger is the psychological state and that love is the psychological
state,
but if we look at our great religious traditions,
Christianity say or Buddhism,
just to take two as an example,
we still have this notion that what these figures represent is something
external.
Well,
you might say how primitive,
right?
Just as primitive as the idea that the god of war is something external,
is the idea that this sort of figure,
it's supposed to be something external.
It's supposed to be something embodied,
right?
It's a story about the nature of individual moral responsibility.
So the idea is something like this,
well,
reality itself,
the existence of things seems to depend on the existence of a finite observer so
that we can see things from a perspective.
If you don't see things from a perspective,
everything is the same.
There's nothing delineated,
but if there's going to be delineated things,
small things,
insufficient things,
and they're going to be aware they're going to be vulnerable as a part of their
limitation.
And so you say,
well,
limitation is a precondition for being and that means suffering is part and
parcel of being.
Dostoevsky.
Said clearly,
look,
I give you all the cake you want,
you got a big house,
you got nothing to do,
but watch TV,
right?
And propagate the species.
Are you happy?
And Dostoevsky says,
well,
no.
Why?
Well,
because human beings are really fundamentally,
you're ungrateful and insane.
So if you give them some little comfortable niche to occupy themselves with so
they don't have anything to worry about.
The first thing they're gonna do,
just like Adam and eve basically are just like Gautama Buddha.
They're going to run around looking for the apple,
looking for the snake,
looking for the trouble to smash the frame into bits,
no matter how comfortable it is,
just so they can get access to little and have some fun.
And so then you think,
well maybe it's more like the purpose of life isn't to avoid chaos because we
like chaos.
It's entertaining,
right?
It keeps us alert and awake and it gives us something to do that really has no
end.
And so maybe the answer is something more like,
well,
forget the frame of reference,
forget the chaos,
but hit the balance right between the two.
Right?
So that you've got one foot where it's reasonably comfortable and you got one
foot out there where it's kind of exciting and dangerous and that's perfect,
and then you think the state you want to attain that makes you resistant to even
the greatest anomalies.
Anomalies of death,
say,
or vulnerability or mortality is exactly.
That's that position,
right balance straight between the forces of chaos and the forces of order or
between Yin and Yang and how do you know you're there because that's what it
really boils down to.
How do you know that you're there and then you think,
okay,
it's pretty simple.
You Watch with your eyes open,
just like Solzhenitsyn Watch.
Do you think I don't know everything,
so let's see what I do.
No,
no preconceptions.
I'm not going to shield myself from the truth with some second rate frame of
reference.
We don't believe in those anyways because they're always fragmental.
I'm just going to watch.
So when am I not miserable?
And then you think,
wow,
I'm not miserable when I'm interested in things.
Something I get interested in,
something I don't exactly know why I get interested in it.
It catches me.
What are the,
what's the phenomenology of being caught,
are not self conscious.
When I'm engaged in something,
I'm more like a child,
which is why children have intimations of immortality.
I mean engaged in this process.
I don't think about myself,
so I'm not self conscious.
I lose my sense of temporality because it seems like I can do whatever it is
that I'm doing thing that I enjoy for hours and the time flies by and I'm not
even really aware of the surrounding world and none of my existential concerns
are paramount at that time.
Every need is suppressed by my engagement in the activity.
And then you say to yourself,
well,
yeah,
I find that only happens like you know,
10 minutes every three days or something when I'm being particularly miserable.
But you might say,
well,
the fact that it happens at all is probably worth paying attention to.
I mean if you believe that your experience is real,
like real,
the fact that you can get into a state like that at all,
it's worth paying attention to.
And so then you might say,
well that's,
that's where your sense of ethics really starts to arise is what makes you
interested.
Well,
it might be just as cracked and,
and,
and peculiar as something you could possibly imagine,
right?
Your parents are against it,
your friends or against it.
Even you're against it when you're thinking clearly,
but there's still this reality that something compels you and then you think,
well,
can you trust it?
And I think,
well that's a tough question because I read a long time for a long time,
I read accounts of serial killers because I was really interested in what
motivated.
Right?
And they're an interesting breed in many ways,
which is why there's such a popular fascination with them.
And so then you think about a story like that and you think,
Geez,
maybe you can't trust your interest,
right?
Maybe it'll take you somewhere.
You don't want to go,
like seriously where you don't want to go.
How do you know that if you really let yourself be who you could be,
that you'd end up somewhere good.
And so then you come to the second part of the story,
which is something like this.
Let's say that you're a very,
very,
very finely tuned biological machine,
right?
Lack into a computer and then you say,
okay,
you take a computer and you feed it false information.
What do you get out?
False information,
right?
Well,
you've stuck with this computer.
It's very complicated.
You kind of reside in it in some manner you don't understand.
And yet you're prone pawn occasions either to deny it information altogether
when you walk away from something you know you shouldn't walk away from or to
it,
bad information.
And so then what if,
what if this was the case?
What if it was the case that the systems that Orient you with regards to your
interest can become pathologized by any relationship you have with yourself
that's predicated on bad faith.
And so then you think,
well,
that's why there's an ethical aspect to this redemptive process.
Like a real strenuous and strict ethical aspect.
It goes something like this.
There are things that you can do.
Find yourself engaged with the world at such a level that your existential
concerns could disappear and we can even understand that biochemically to some
degree because if you're really interested in something,
you get a dopamine release,
an exploratory dopamine release,
that's great.
I mean that's associated with positive effect with confidence,
with increased immunological functioning,
with better memory functioning with learning everything you want.
It's also potently antianxiety,
lytic and analgesic,
which means that if you're really pursuing something that's compelling to you,
you're much more resistant biochemically to punishment,
disappointment,
depression,
pain,
threat,
et Cetera,
and it's not because you're blind,
you're blind.
It's because your nervous system is optimally tuned to make you maximally
resistant,
and so then you might think if you were optimally tuned,
how resistant would you be?
You don't know,
right?
Because it's a spiral that never stops moving uphill.
We don't know what the upper mds and we have exemplars that might indicate what
that upper end could be,
but we don't actually know.
So then you think,
okay,
well here's the.
Here's the rule.
Say something like this.
If you look at the world from this perspective,
which is something you have to decide if you're,
you know,
you find compelling and reasonable.
The rule is this,
you're always gonna run into it normally,
right?
And,
uh,
normally is always going to look to look to you like,
like this,
and it's no bloody wonder.
You want to run away from that.
I mean in some ways is your whole body's telling you watch out and for good
reason because it's no joke,
but then it was more to the story because the anomalous thing,
that's everything you don't know.
And you might say,
well,
you're going out with someone and you want to have a longterm relationship.
They'd be true.
How could there be any good in that?
Because that's certainly what you're going to ask when you first encounter the
unexpected information,
but then you might think could be that I'm a little too naive for my own good,
right?
People pull me in a little more than they should or I'm not sufficiently careful
when I enter into intimate relationships with people or I don't treat people
right or I don't have a good conceptualization of myself or I'm chasing after
the wrong person.
Well,
that's all going to be very annoying to learn,
but if you don't learn it,
you're going to be in big trouble.
So maybe the best thing to do and enormity of that sort hits you is to think,
okay,
yeah,
it's a dragon.
No doubt it will eat me,
but if I don't let it eat me,
then they'll just be another one waiting around the corner and it'll probably be
a little bit bigger and if I get eaten by enough of them,
I'm not really gonna want to be around much and maybe I'm not going to be
willing to help other people be around much either.
It doesn't seem like a very good alternative to me.
Back in 1957,
some new gnostic writings were discovered in a and a cave.
They were discovered by these two Arab guys who went out to kill the man who
killed her father.
They took them out into this cave.
Then they killed them and when they were burying them,
they found exam for a full of papers and papyrus and they took them home and
their mother used a bunch of them too,
like cooking fires with and one day one of their friends who was an antiquities
dealer showed up and he said,
you know,
you shouldn't be burning those.
Those are about 1500 years old and they look like very early gnostic gospels and
the Gnostics were this branch of Christianity that was pretty violently
suppressed by the emergence of Orthodox Christianity and the gnostics believed
that faith was a good thing,
but knowledge was all right too.
And they wrote Gospel accounts say of Christ's life that were knowledge
predicated as much as revelation predicated.
Say,
and this is one of the quotes from one of those Gospels,
the Gospel of Thomas,
which is actually one that the only one that got out,
Carl young got ahold of them.
Interestingly enough,
and this is one of the quotes and I really liked this,
this is a non canonical saying of Christ and the saying is,
if you bring forth what is within you,
why don't you bring forth will save you.
If you do not bring forth what is within you,
what you do not bring forth will destroy you,
and I think that's a pretty good line to close off the class.